that's a badge number there you want to
make the call or you want me to file a
complaint I have all night to fill out
paperwork ain't that right baby
damn straight that's a clip from Crown
Heights the 2017 film produced and
co-starring Nnamdi Asomugha the film is
one in his growing body of work which
includes acting and producing if Ava's
name sounds familiar it may not actually
be from the big screen for eleven years
he starred in the NFL and in his prime
he was considered one of the league's
best defensive backs so how did he go
from making plays to his latest project
acting in one I caught up with osawa a
few weeks ago to find out for more than
a decade NFL Nnamdi Asomugha built a
reputation as an elite defender a
playmaker is billing now is a bit
different right before you come out on
this stage are you nervous
oh yeah yeah yeah were you nervous when
you used to get ready to play a game Oh
without a doubt but you know if you
don't feel anything then you're not
alive you know that's what I think
Peterson oh I forgot shoot boy time to
teach you a lesson
once you drop dead thought earlier this
month
awesome wah made his Broadway debut in
the Pulitzer winning a soldier's play
just six years after retiring from the
NFL I started the decade at the Pro Bowl
and I ended the decade on Broadway I was
like this is really surreal this is not
a dream that I ever had right and now
this is so clearly what I should be
doing as a kid in Southern California
the son of Nigerian immigrants awesome
was parents dreamt he'd become a doctor
or lawyer but he had something else in
mind
I loved playing basketball when I was a
kid I think the only real dream that I
ever had was to play for the Lakers and
that got shut down I think my sophomore
year in high school but yeah my brother
it was really my mentor and his thing
was football and so they got me in the
football even then ASIMO says the dream
wasn't the NFL
that was just the path he ended up on so
when you finish your 11 year NFL career
do you start thinking what's next well
you better start thinking long before I
mean I started noticing from really my
first year and then FL that you can go
down with an injury your career can be
over you could get cut you know within
moments and then what are you gonna do
the answer for awesome while while still
playing part-time work as a TV analyst
which put him alongside me on espn2 best
defense left in the playoffs nominee who
is it if I'm going with the Jets I mean
I did it with you but I also did it with
NBC I did it just so many different but
you loved it with the ESPN and on the
show that I did but I loved it more you
know it wasn't that better but yeah I
did it so much at some point I just said
I don't know that this is gonna be it I
think there's something else there was
thanks in part to a TV commercial the
director pulled me aside and he was like
why you've got great ability I mean very
natural and this is not something that I
see often with athletes this is
something you should really think about
when you're done playing then a couple
months later he called me he says you
know I want you to be a part of my show
Friday Night Lights
you've heard of cops and jocks right
close yeah second chance be a second
chance program you know we just brought
this kid in this morning the show's
director Peter Berg cast awesome wha in
a cameo during the NFL offseason that
confidence from him I think was
something that kept me going down the
path so when awesome well retired from
football at the end of the 2013 NFL
season he set his sights on acting I was
a rookie again so I had to start from
zero you take classes and it's okay that
as I'm doing Taming of the Shrew you're
seeing a football player but it's okay
you know this is part of the process
awesome was first big film credit would
come not as an actor but executive
producer on the acclaimed Netflix film
beasts of no nation then in 2017 the
movie Crown Heights this is a man's life
you're dealing with this time not just a
producing credit but
also a Supporting Actor role for which
he received three Award nominations the
truth is going to come out I knew that
if I could produce if I could create my
own work then people would be able to
see that I'm an actor versus just saying
he's just a football player you get to
choose the role you're going to play
exactly but it was on the stage not the
big screen where awesome were found a
feeling he once thought was reserved for
football I was doing a reading of a play
in New York there was a little holding
room and that was like essentially the
locker room where all the actors were
you go after through like a tunnel this
thing that's very similar to what you're
going out onto a field on they announce
you everyone's cheering and then we kind
of ran onto the stage and began our work
and I remember at that moment just being
like this is where I'm supposed to be
dressing yes this is it that led awesome
walk to a soldier's play a World War 2
era drama dealing with racial tension
within a Louisiana Army unit and just
want to be in the space yeah you know
that time period there were a lot of
actors I have to think who never want to
do Broadway it's live you don't get a
second take but that's football isn't it
it is it's live you don't get a second
right and I developed that muscle so
much I'm at my best when I'm in the fire
he plays private first class Melvin
Peterson I don't get smart
hands off me you want to hit old
sergeant waters boy working alongside
veteran actors blair Underwood Jerry
O'Connell and david alan grier I've
never seen a person who can't act being
taught how to act because you just can't
they have to have something to work with
yes he does
he's really gifted and he's really great
and I don't think most people who come
to the show know of his past I agree but
his fellow actors did I knew Nandi is
the shutdown corner and I'm embarrassed
to say this just asked him to look at my
fantasy lineup and just say Dee what do
you think about this and you'd be like
I'm trying to concentrate on this
Broadway show that was yeah but could
you just
look at this how do you think the
Baltimore defense will do this weekend
but I have to be honest with you he blew
me away when we first did our rehearsal
just as he did on the football field
which in awesome was eyes was the
perfect preparation for this
do you miss football yes you know that
was a great time for both definitely my
first love and now finding this world
and entertainment through acting and
producing I didn't think that I would
love something you know so much as I did
but I'm so grateful you know now that I
do it was great to watch him in a lot of
those things because I wasn't watching
the Nnamdi that I knew that I had worked
with it really was watching a character
should point out he is married to Carrie
Washington force now I say that because
I asked him the impact that that has and
he said really it's about just
supporting each other supporting each
other in the projects that we do and
obviously she has a knowledge in the
industry that he didn't going in his
next movie went to Sundance Silver's
love these love friend of mine it's
producing him in that and she said what
a joy every day they're gonna work with
him yeah he's a great guy
you